the Oregon will get the first glimpse of
the eclipse coast-to-coast up to a
million people are expected to visit the
state the small town of Madras is now
hosting more than a hundred thousand
tourists hotels are fully booked
so most visitors are camping Jamie
yuccas is at one of the campsites Jamie
good morning good morning Anthony it is
crazy out here this is one of the
campsites called solar town where they
are allowing five a thousand different
spots to be set up with six people in
each of those spots and they are all
sold out this is just one of 25 camp
sites around Madras right now where
people are hoping to witness history in
Madras Oregon the countdown is on and
the town is packed they do some camping
visitors spent hours waiting in traffic
over the weekend so they could be some
of the first in the country to watch the
total eclipse more than a hundred
thousand people representing 50 states
and more than 30 countries have traveled
to this small city seeing how nice
everyone has and how excited everyone
has for it it's just like the experience
that we're all here for the same reason
some here had an opportunity to see the
last total eclipse in the US in 1979 but
92 year old Jeanne brick missed it now
he's sharing in it with the Sun bar you
have another opportunity to see it this
time I'm prepared yeah it's up to the
Sun in the moon to give us what we
missed Madras is now a mecca for Eclipse
enthusiasts because historic data on
cloud cover shows it's one of the town's
most likely to have clear skies along
the line of totality even those who
haven't waited decades like
four-year-olds secure about Missoni can
feel the excitement it's gonna be dark
right Wow well cuz the moon is gonna
touch the Sun so the lights gonna go
away
go away now people here will need to
have these Eclipse glasses ready to go
because here in Madras they get 30 fewer
seconds of viewing than other places
around the country because of how organ
is tilted further away from the moon
Anthony Jamie thanks